there's just time to bring you more now
on that developing story this evening
that a teenager has been arrested on
suspicion of murder after a six year old
boy was thrown from a tenth floor
viewing platform at the Tate Modern
gallery in London the child was
airlifted to hospital in a critical
condition police service say there's
nothing to suggest that he and the
suspect are known to each other
allarakha Chinese food dispute is at the
Tate Modern for us this evening
tell us more Ali yeah so there's about
6:40 this afternoon that the
Metropolitan Police were called here to
the Tate Modern to reports that a child
a six-year-old child had been thrown
from a height now as you say police say
that child is now in a critical
condition
the air ambulance were here earlier the
child was treated at the scene before
being taken to hospital now police say
that the child fell from the 10th floor
viewing platform which you can see right
at the top of the tape Brittain behind
me and police say that he was then found
on the fifth floor roof people on
Twitter have said that they saw a child
trapped between the two buildings here
now the Tate Modern remains closed for
the rest of the day they say that parts
of the building were on lockdown parts
in the building were evacuated following
the incident this obviously is one of
the busiest tourist hotspots in London
undoubtedly on a sunny Sunday afternoon
would have had thousands of visitors
would have been packed out with visitors
and met police as you say have arrested
a 17 year old on suspicion of murder
they say there's nothing to suggest that
the 17 year old knew the family all the
16 year old child and they're asking
anyone with any information to contact
them okay Allie thanks very much indeed
well we'll have more on that developing
picture in the next hour as Allie was
saying that breaking news this evening
that a 17 year old has been arrested for
attempted murder of an unknown to him
six-year-old boy thrown from the Tate
Modern in